[Musique]
bonjour il avait hâte de feydeau à
jean-pierre annick mercier d'être sur le
plateau de tv fils pour un vip qui vous
est donc consacrée nous allons parler en
fait de tout ce que vous faites en ce
moment et il faut dire qu'elle la
matière et déjà je vais vous présenter
vous êtes historienne de parfum vous
avez fait un doctorat sur le parfum
l'histoire du parfum contemporain on
peut dire ça oui absolument la sorbonne
à la sorbonne très bien après vous avez
travaillé pour des grandes marques de
luxe de parfums français et après vous
avez monté votre société arty fragrance
en tant que consultante et aussi en tant
que créatrice d'une gamme de bougies
parfumées d'autres parfums d'intérieur
etc
qu'est ce que j'ai oublié à leurs
économies et sur vous alors écoutez
alors je suis toujours consultant pour
les grandes marques de parfums d'accord
aujourd'hui j'interviens toujours voilà
chez elle dans différents à différents
niveaux de consultation que ce soit la
communication de la création etc
et effectivement j'ai créé en 2011 une
marque de parfums d'ambiance et de
parfums bougies parfumées inspiré donc
par versailles par xviiie siècle sous le
nom de parti fragrance voilà ce qu'on
disait et vous est aussi professeur est
visible qu'à l'école de parfums à
versailles
absolument voilà donc au fait la vôtre
comment dire vous allez faire un voyage
à new york récemment et vous étiez un
peu l'ambassadrice du savoir faire
français dans votre domaine
c'était quoi cette histoire pouvez nous
raconter alors oui tout à fait le
magazine magnificence qui était un très
bon magazine de luxe
américain avait organisé avec le
consulat de france de new york
une manifestation consacrée au french
savoir faire et ils avaient donc comme
ça sélectionné un certain nombre de
maisons
il y avait par exemple la maison lison
de caunes qui fait de la marque et
ripailles savoir faire français unique
extraordinaire
il y avait un horloger il y avait
également un herboristerie un herboriste
et il avait donc sélectionner notre
gamme de bougies parfumées retire
fragrance parce qu'ils estimaient que ça
correspondait à ce french avoir faire
donc on a eu la chance et l'opportunité
de présenter donc lors d'une grande
soirée à new york à l'ambassade de
france au consulat de france près de
central pas donc notre gamme de bougies
et puis de témoigner donc sur le frêne
savoir faire par rapport à la création
des bougies et aider et des parfums
n'est pas absolument tradition française
qui remonte à château de versailles à
louis xiv louis donc ça beaucoup de
diamants aux états unis s'est énormément
d'impact et c'était très intéressant
comme comme soirée des changes
et puis bien sûr de présentation alors
quelle a été la réaction des américains
j'avais été produit et ben écoute est
excellente un des rares relâchements
quelle chance quand même bon les
américains il aime beaucoup les bougies
parfumées ils ont énormément énormément
c'est un très gros marché
donc c'est vrai qu'ils ont et puis ils
sont très sensibles ou 18e ces français
au château de versailles enfin bon tout
ça ça les intéresse beaucoup
donc oui on a eu on a eu un très bel
accueil d'écouté en hectares avec des
valises pleines on est repartis avec des
manèges lidar effectivement c'est moi le
signe est ce qu'il ya une
un phénomène sofia coppola aussi par
rapport aux films ou de mariée sur marie
antoinette pas spécialement si ça
continue un petit peu mais maintenant
c'est vrai que ça commence à dater un
petit peu mais oui il ya toujours
mutation ça remonte même pas sofia
coppola c'est bien avant les américaines
french à versailles enfin etc ils sont
ils sont très sensibles à l'art de vivre
français puis à priori si vous voulez
les invités présents étaient à
l'ambassade de france au consulat de
france et il était invité par un
magazine qui célébrait le french avoir
fermé son côté relativement sensibles
comme la machine voilà d'accord donc
après après new york
vous êtes allé à tokyo oui juste après
voilà on enchaîné voile et or là dans
quel à quelle occasion
alors en fait à tokyo j'y suis allé une
première fois dans le cadre d'un
lancement d'une marque qui m'avait
demandé d'être consultante pour eux
c'était une marque de tissus d'ambiance
tissu d'intérieur plus exactement
inspiré par le 18e sept français et donc
j'avais rencontré un certain nombre de
personnalités déjà là bas et pas tout à
fait un an plus tard donc mon agent
japonaise yoko nakamura que vous voyez
ici m'appelle en me disant que la ville
de tokyo organise un voyage
d'influenceurs d'ambassadeur si vous
voulez pour communiquer sur la ville de
tokyo dans le cadre du
dans le cadre de
des jeux olympiques de 2020 voilà
d'accord déjà juste honteux retour en
arrière influenceurs ça veut dire quoi
influenceurs c'est des personnalités qui
vont pouvoir parler communiqué être un
peu des ambassadeurs si vous voulez de
d'une ville ou de l'aréna en deux temps
exergue leur pays équivaut à l'air leur
à côté ou racault joliment jack straw
vrai qu'on nous a fait vivre et nec
énormément d'expérience là bas oui elle
à bord a reçu des gens n'a été reçue
dans un hôtel extraordinaire qui venait
d'ouvrir ses portes au plein coeur de
tokyo
le china hôtel qui est sa place si vous
voulez mais qui est conçu comme une
maison traditionnelle japonaise géante
incroyable avec un onsen le monde
certainement le hauts-de-seine c'est le
bain traditionnel qui est sûr le rooftop
de cet hôtel je le crois le rouge c'est
à dire le toit terrasse de l'hôtel
d'alcool ou là vous vivez en fait des
expériences totalement traditionnelle
vous êtes reçu comme si vous étiez dans
une maison traditionnelle japonaise mais
que tu oses un pardon le dans votre
barre là on est plusieurs comme dans un
jacuzzi oui alors ces hommes et femmes
on est plusieurs ce sont des bains en
fait ce sont des eaux volcanique si vous
voulez des eaux chaudes des eaux
incroyable et alors c'est relaxant s'est
plaint de minéraux c'est plein de choses
excellentes pour la peau pour
l'organisme donc c'est quelque chose que
les c'est une pratique si vous voulez
millénaire que les japonais continuent
de faire est là s'est revu et corrigé
avec la mode contemporaine mois l'accord
donc ça c'était une des expériences
après vous avez eu droit j'imagine à la
cérémonie du tabac bien sûr on a fait la
cérémonie du thé avec un moine de kyoto
qui était venu donc qui dans cette
petite maison du thé à tokyo donc on a
vraiment vécu toute cette cérémonie qui
durent très longtemps
c'est une cérémonie c'est comme un c'est
comme un rituel si vous voulez c'est
quasi richesse à mais pratiquement oui
tout à fait il ya s'ennuie pas du tout
parce qu'il se passe toujours plein de
choses on mange énormément de choses
il ya ensuite la préparation inculte et
non pas du tout il ya d'abord un repas
et ensuite à cette préparation du thé
qui est un thé vert très concentré qu'on
appelle le match a été très dur à
préparer d'ailleurs et on le voit faire
avec une dextérité
il ya énormément de concentration de
rituels un gestuel
chaque geste a un sens très particulier
se fait avec lenteur face est
exceptionnel à vivre vraiment ça dure
qu'on met dedans ça dure deux heures a
quand même nom et ça peut durer plus
longtemps mon dieu après il ya la
cérémonie du côlon comme godot alors là
ce rideau du caudeau en fait vous
écoutez les parfums et là aussi ça fait
appel aux sens à la concentration
au zen si vous voulez le zen en fait ça
veut dire être silencieux 1 c'est tout à
fait un trou c'est une introspection et
donc sur kodo qui est aussi un art
millénaire japonais au début a commencé
donc à la cour impériale et c'était une
véritable joute si vous voulez
olfactives c'est un jeu c'est une forme
de jeu on vous apprend à écouter les
parfums et comment ils ont pu être
intéressant tu es bon ben voila vous
voyez cette femme avait en kimono et
elle sort les parfums et elle va
chercher à les reconnaître et enfin donc
cette reconnaissance du parfum val lui
inspirer une thématique politique
un peu comme vous savez ce qu'ils
appellent et les poneys les a exactement
les haïkus donc ses poneys et de ses
poèmes ses poèmes très rapide
oui ces petites phrases exactement et
donc chaque parfum que vous écoutez va
vous inspirer une pensée politique
dahico voilà à nice et du coup on vous
la faire vous ça absolument et l'art il
faut reconnaître dont tous et en sang
les inscrire les classer par famille est
ensuite donc elle vous révèle là la
solution du jeu quand en gros c'est ça
génial un travail en équipe
on joue en équipe oui mais laïque où il
sert de vous tout seul alors nous on n'a
pas fait les coûts parce qu'on a
japonais on ne compare pas moins que
tous les cas je parle pas de japonais
abonnés non ils nous ont fait uniquement
reconnaître mais si on allait jusqu'au
bout
de l'exercice il faudrait voilà avoir
une pensée poétique génial bon pour
aller un tout petit peu plus vite vous
êtes aussi c'est quoi ces histoires de
beauté électronique l'amour c'est ça qui
est fascinant japon si vous voulez si
vous avez à la fois l'extrême traditions
millénaires et en même temps
l'hypermodernité donc là je suis à la
fois avec les deux blogueuses les plus
influentes du moment jumelles elles sont
jumelles elles sont toutes jeunes elles
sont incroyables elles ont lancé aussi
leur marque de vêtements et je suis avec
une vieille geisha qui est toujours la
directrice d'une école de geisha parce
que ça existe toujours
donc c'est ça qui est très contrastée en
japonais en trois modèles à 10 des voix
les lancers voilà d'accord et 7,7 beauté
électronique
alors ça c'est encore autre chose dit
moi vu ce que ça leur l'électro beauté
sa d'électro beauté voilà c'est un
carton en asie pas qu'au japon également
en corée en chine un leader c'est
panasonic et panasonic introduit sa en
france et donc j'ai des martyrs aux
amants abbas est en fait des appareils
incroyable qui vont vous aider à être
jeune à une belle être encore plus
compétents attentes bien sûr celle
instituée en 2006 et donc panasonic
avait réuni les miss internationale à
tokyo que j'ai rencontrés n'ont pas
besoin voilà avec qui nous avons parlé
beauté c'était très amusant vous voyez
ici avec toutes ses plus jeunes
internationales qui avait été invité par
panasonic pour découvrir toutes ces
machines extraordinaires et donc
je discutais avec elle deux sens de la
beauté
je sens rassurez-vous véronique
d'électro beauté arrive en france raouf
puisque pas d'ailleurs mika introduit
tous ces appareils dans quelques centres
des distributions en fait depuis le mois
d'octobre
bientôt nous pourrons jouir de la voix
la même beauté est aussi belle que les
chercheurs parce que les japonaises ont
une peau est extraordinaire c'est vrai
mais oui elles ont une une peau une
qualité de peau qu'elles entretiennent
très bien d'ailleurs
mais absolument incroyable rabin c'est
pour bientôt pour les 16e un petit clin
d'oeil à christine bravo vous êtes aussi
comment on peut dire quel est votre rôle
dans son émission sous les jupons de
l'histoire mâchez experts ou aux côtés
d'autres en fait c'est ça le santon
d'experts absolue choisi une
personnalité historique féminine oui
voilà
et elle va creuser un côté de sa vie qui
est moins en moins connus en fait elle
traite château la banalité si vous
voulez donc c'est toujours des femmes
évidemment sur julian moore et c'est
traité comme un magazine actuel donc on
va là des problématiques modernes a eu
les marionnettes faisant par exemple il
ya parmi les experts et stéphane clerget
qui est médecin et qui nous fait à la
fois le bilan de santé et la sexo du la
rubrique sexuelle dont fait alors moi je
m'occupe en général de la jeunesse des
doazit
de ses relations avec les enfants la
maternité enfin ça dépend mais d'accord
la vie politique la vie littéraire donc
là cette gestion sûre chez les 25 oui
voilà présenté là on est haché une
brouille d'ailleurs on highway la
surface la cave à nu on espère que ça
continue on est déjà la saison de succès
c'est un très beau succès l'on puisse à
une ambiance d'équipé extraordinaire
donc on a tous très envie que ça
continue
bon ben écoutez on vous retrouve sur tv
fils oui déjà
et après éventuellement sur série chérie
25 et très bientôt merci pour ce voyage
un peu accéléré mais néanmoins j 100 et
est plein de nouvelles connaissances un
au revoir et rnic
[Musique]